yeah welcome to the splits video and
5-minute let's go let's go let's go what
didn't I flew ok let's let's play the
Bangko if he goes for it and he accepted
the pawn not to play b6 yeah this is a
good line for white which I if I'm not
mistaken also recommended in my video
series I don't really know much about
this that's playing very quickly I
wonder this a5 could be it could be an
issue white going for a 5 but he doesn't
develop his pieces ok I wonder if I am
I'm able to yeah what's the downside of
all this it's very slow and developing
the kingside can I use this in some way
I'm thinking about a move like Bishop f5
for example with the idea to go 90 form
come on let's play mafia not spent so
much time it's a bit uncommon to push
the a pawn so early
yeah after I hoped out for that and now
I dropped back here to play we should be
five
I thought f3 would be a would be a
weakness of course this urn or we can
play Knight b6 or I forgot about that
Knight b6 rook s7 Bishop b5 would be
quite quite quite an embarrassment
probably ok don't need to take
immediately I can play a couple of
strengthening moves first
so here
yeah I can always take here and hope to
have some play on the B phone and three
is not or not to move white likes to
play in general and this structure it's
a bit weakening it's not so clear what
is Rufus now he cannot really move the
c1 bishop of course I just take is c4
I'd be too can what maybe one idea was
Knight e3 I could have taken it five
okay so do I have any more moves that
are rather helpful here could go here
it's not bad
intending 97 to b5
so drawback unprepared night to see
seven I wonder if if night a three at
some point is an idea so that she
exchanges bishop against Bishop
yeah probably it doesn't matter so much
spending lots of time this is always
always a cause for optimism okay captain
if I ever sir it's hard to play
it just he just goes for it hmm yeah
it's that so dangerous come on let's
let's take here take your five yeah this
is kind of a show me attitude but what
can you do I probably needed to take it
what now f5 yeah it's a it's not
ridiculous
okay so
yeah the question is how do I would love
to get a knight on d4 of course I come
on let's let's not spend too much time
so it's it looks it looks really
dangerous for black if there's something
here on f7 or maybe you can even take
now you can take he can probably take
now take a seven if I take on Bishop f7
king of some creepy three check I need
to go to some very ugly squares
maybe after Bishop f7 I need to okay
didn't play it maybe I need to play King
King King h8 this is a text now the
bishop and tell us okay now this this
should be okay I hope I'm c5 is saying
c5 is saying okay but anyway it's it's
probably probably okay for blanket so in
some way
takes takes somewhere a bit of d6s a
possibility I can't take it yeah well
let's let's just take a five
Bishop d6 I go and look somewhere I Roxy
aid or something
intending 94 if possible what is it
after all of this is just an extra poem
yeah if seven was was hanging in some
some way the threatens Queen b6 o market
take I can take here
doesn't this Winnie peace I hope at
least
Quinn is hanging now he can go Queen d7
but I have 96 that should should save
save the day or even even this first
sure
yeah come on let's let's take it can I
have seven and think about that now
Queen a seven now but he gets the six at
the end I can go to f5 though yeah just
a five yeah of course not it's just just
a piece a queen a seven would have been
a check-in even
yeah I will not time Jeff
we have two sizes alter fancy queen f2 -
should be working
it's an extra rock
like working on time yeah this was this
was shaking I don't know
around here I really had some doubts
about my position maybe it is is okay
but yeah Bishop F 7/8 is working I just
checked it here with the computer you
can take on f7 it needs to I am it I
cannot take it I need to just briefly
back up to this here if he takes
I cannot capture queen bee three years
is terrible I have no square for the
King something like this is just just
disaster I have to I have to go to age 8
and then yeah maybe it's something like
this
it's very very dangerous
he's not even a pawn down or something
no it's just a brilliant position for
what yeah I probably am I would have won
that I don't know if it looks it looks
terrible computers on +2 at least it's a
bit tricky so but it's objectively lost
for black yeah I took this a bit too
lightly this be fine
but it seems to work
maybe this was was all a chat too slow
again I can do various things yeah I can
take on C 495 before all kinds of moves
maybe it was a bit too slow but I did
yeah interesting game thanks for
watching